un proyecto histórico y transformador
así presenta la casa blanca el gran
programa de inversiones sometido este
viernes a la cámara de representantes-
una votación que cierra una saga de
meses de discusiones en el seno del
partido demócrata
no podemos esperar tenemos que avanzar
debemos hacerlo por el pueblo
estadounidense tenemos que hacer todo lo
necesario para invertir en
infraestructuras y en recursos sociales
un proyecto con dos ramas por un lado un
paquete de 12 billones de dólares para
renovar las grandes infraestructuras
deterioradas del país como las
carreteras los puentes y las estructuras
del transporte público por otro lado un
plan de 175 millones bautizado build
back better destinado a políticas
sociales y medioambientales por ejemplo
la base de los servicios de guardería o
la reducción de emisiones de efecto
invernadero de aquí a 2030 reputado por
ser un audaz negociador joe biden ha
tenido que lidiar con las diferencias
entre las salas centrista y progresista
de su partido en el senado el demócrata
joe manchin amenaza con oponerse al
proyecto de ley preocupado por las
eventuales consecuencias de tal
inversión la deuda pública y en la
inflación él solo ostenta casi un
derecho de veto debido al poco margen de
mayoría demócrata en la cámara alta por
su lado la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi declaró su
confianza con el proyecto tras las
últimas enmiendas
hemos hecho algunos cambios desde la
semana pasada la gente tiene que
familiarizarse con ellos fue el objetivo
de nuestra reunión de esta mañana estoy
muy orgullosa e inspirada una vez más
por el simple hecho de haber escuchado
la profundidad de los conocimientos de
nuestros colegas tras la derrota
demócrata en las elecciones a la
gobernación de virginia yoga aire
necesita más que nunca la aprobación de
este plan de inversiones para relanzar
su cuestionada presidencia